[Music]
hello everyone its Perry here in Park
City we are at the Kia Telluride supper
suite with the folks behind beast beast
congratulations guys
we have to start I'm sure you're gonna
answer this question a million times
Spain and of course the festival but a
lot of people out there do not know what
beast beast is so can you give them the
brief synopsis a brief it's three
interweaving stories three main
characters in a southern town and it's
sort of like they each have their own
journey and involves young love and
petty crime and there's some gun stuff
in there and it all kind of comes
together job well done
a lot going on there though what was the
starting point was there any particular
point of inspiration to build the rest
of the story around yeah so a few years
back we made a short film with Shirley
that will and I wrote and called krysta
and that like as we were finishing that
it was sort of it felt like time to
expand it and work more with Shirley and
with Will and sort of like build a
bigger world out around what that short
was so after the success of that short
did you find that it was maybe somewhat
easy to get the feature off the ground
or what was the what was the time where
the feature became like the real deal we
turned around I had a rough rough draft
of the script at South by Southwest when
it premiered and then it was received
well so the next day we launched we
stayed up all night and we made a
Kickstarter video to raise
pre-production funds and we announced it
and we just went straight into it and
then Alec and Casey Bader they're
producing producing partners came in and
a few months later we were filming it
did you write half of the short and you
won't have to short my sincerest at the
good news to you should I go do you want
to sit here well maybe so when you wrote
these so Alec did you want to jump in
right after see my partner Casey Bader
who I work with in our company we he got
me a bunch of shorts and we try to look
at shorts as a way to find filmmakers we
like and do they
expand that piece of material or do
something like that piece of material
they would change it or do something
another script they have and we thought
that Danny had every complete ingredient
to really make a great film he's free
he's wonderful
the writing and the camerawork well the
writing that he did the writing and the
camera were directing actors everything
everything he did a great job and so we
said yes we want to develop this into a
feature he sent us the script did you
write part of the script the main script
I did not gonna touch it I didn't let
him look at the nobody he said is the
scripted we loved the script and we
decided we wanted helped make the moment
so I love hearing about familiar actors
like Alec getting in and helping getting
a project off the ground that might not
have without his touch on it so can you
tell me a little bit about working with
him as an executive producer right well
we were kind of we were going we were
running straight at it we were like
we're gonna do this if we have $5
amongst the sign of us and we were gonna
just we were plunging and that was the
idea like very much like the people we
work with Ben weasoner Jim Cummings we
have this idea of like you plant the
flag and you go and you and and the
thing will become real around it and and
it was just like a real step up I mean
how it came in and and like we really
were able to do it in a way that was
more than what we could had foreseen so
I also like hearing about brothers that
work together so nicely I love my sister
to death but one time we tried working
together and it didn't go very well so
what was the reason we're sitting this
far apart yeah I'm not gonna make eye
contact with contractually we can we
positioned you that way but it does seem
like you have a wonderful collaboration
so growing up when did you guys realize
that you guys want to make movies
together Danny made me be an actor when
I was five he forced me into it and then
we've been doing it ever since and then
I kind of went my own path and then
we're kind of back together now but we
just have like a like a fluency that's
kind of nonverbal you know we just like
give a look it was like okay cool we'll
try it differently we don't really
there's not like BS around around
collaborative it's gonna go is it funny
how it is like that when you're a kid
where like with everybody with my
friends who had a camera we were kids it
was a different theme but I can just see
you guys and you're like but I don't
want to put
the Cape it is like putting on the
classic Stockholm Syndrome and here we
are
is there any like sibling rivalry or
bickering I feel like I shouldn't ask
you guys this for surely no say like
what what happens when they disagree on
something I don't think I ever saw them
disagreeing I mean never disagreed and I
actually know we had a pretty pretty you
know I sort of knew what I was doing so
to an extent and then he just kind of I
don't know well there's a lot of trust
and and our the process that we've come
up with and this applies to these guys
too is like is this sort of like
iterative sort of take after take we're
pushing it we're doing various versions
of the scene we treat each take like a
like a theater rehearsal right and we
say oh that was a really great one but
like let's try one where like you're not
making eye to eye contact so much like
let's see what that brings out in the
same way that you would want to just
like stretch and bend a scene in in a
you know a blank room kind of theatrical
space we're doing that and we're rolling
that's the beauty of like shooting on
like digital it's like we can just keep
going and going and when we get to find
all these discoveries and especially
with people who had less acting
experience to really like like blossom
out and like trust that the best parts
are gonna be put together and made into
what the scene I was like he's told me a
little bit about your background I was
reading the notes and I there was some
sort of connection made through the the
sign spinning scene yeah world-champion
sign spinner 2017 I didn't realize that
was a thing that's the thing so so that
and stunt work yeah and stunt work and
skateboarding and Academy of villains
hip hop company so I like to dance and
do crazy stuff we met through Sean wells
the color artists of beasts peas and
then we just met up in Los Angeles and
we just filmed some skateboarding stuff
just for fun I just bobbed out
wait like fathers that's sick it was
close this is gonna happen feel like we
should make a movie about that behind
the scenes stories so are you allowed to
do your own stunts in the movie cuz I
know sometimes when you're the lead
actor in a movie you got to get a stunt
double but are you all clear to do it I
did all the stunts okay well that was
part of it we wanted to it kind of in
ingratiate what like Jose's like even
the fact that he can just like hey we
have to like land a kickflip in this
scene on a skateboard so but having hoes
they do it we're acting in the scene and
you can do this thing where you can go
from a close-up of one character and pan
the camera he does the kickflip when we
come up when we see Jose and it's and
it's not like you know actor like starts
to slide out a frame cut two legs
kickflip cut back to actor like aren't I
cool it's just like it becomes this
thing that you can be fluid and I think
it like helped us to sort of like keep
that naturalism in the film is to have
Jose actually doing those things West
you yeah um so they were casting Christa
and they were actually shooting it in
the performing arts high school that I
went to and they decided you know why
don't we send on an open casting call in
the theatre department so I got this
email figured I wasn't doing anything
better and so I just went in for them I
met these two guys and they were their
typical goofy selves and it was just the
most comfortable most freeing like
auditions experience I really have maybe
ever had um and that was how we got
connected through Christa and Christa
became you know you know they morphed
into the beast beast and you know Alex
signed on and it became this whole thing
yeah and the role was written for you
right yeah it was you find cuz I assume
Christa that was not the case cuz you
auditions you finds it easier to slip in
and into a role that was written for you
or maybe one that's a little different
than who you are in real life huh I
actually felt that in beast beast the
moments that I felt like it could be the
most mice
just happened to be when I was working
with other people who kind of brought
that out of me so I especially working
with Courtney who plays Krista's best
friend in the in the film and Ian Jose
and it's like the people that Christos
closest to I feel like that was when I
could really let go and be myself and so
I think that that was I think what
contributed most to that and beast beast
are you guys super into music like I
could have just watched you guys at that
table scene just like creating beats all
day long that's what he does all the
time what I'd like to add is to be very
real and sincere thank you to Sundance
because you know you when you come here
and we're walking around and lin-manuel
Miranda is coming out of door and Glenn
Close is coming out of door and Buscemi
and so forth and you see established
people here who are making films are
just great because you know you you want
to enjoy whatever films that are here
but this is for emerging filmmakers
really that's what it's about and it's a
great opportunity I mean a big thank you
to Sundance for having this film in the
festival and we're very grateful to them
I would echo that that's part of the
reason why I was so excited to jump into
this because it's so exciting to meet
new filmmakers that I can't wait to see
grow from here
speaking of which going from the short
to a feature with Danny how would you
say he grew as a director yeah this is
where all the dirt on Danny comes out um
I would say that between Kristin beast
appease Danny and I got a lot closer I
think that just the process of krysta
and then you know we had long car rides
where we were driving to film festivals
and we were just talking about life and
who Christa was and and what it means to
grow up in a small town and so I think
that the biggest things I saw between
those two were just the changing and our
relationships in the comfortability with
actors and kind of finding new fluencies
like I mean like you know we'll was
talking about how he has its great
fluency with Danny but I think that
Danny does this great job of he's very
immediate connections with people and
when he's working with them and so I
think from Christa to be spiesse it was
really nice to see him work with new
people and work with more people I mean
like there were so many like extra
scenes and I
I could you know which we didn't really
have as much of during krysta and so I
think just working on bigger things but
I think the one thing that kept Danielle
was grounded was you know this sense of
connection and an excitement and I want
to ask you how has Dani grown as a
director since you did Star Wars in your
backyard in 1995 yeah it was all
downhill from there that was his best
work and now he's grown a lot I think
we've kind of been like kind of training
and teaching each other you know as I
kind of trained in my field he trained
in Hays and we kind of in tandem have
grown and I think like specifically
minoo I I've seen you really allow the
actors to to bring their own artistry
and interpretation to it and really say
this is that they're gonna bring
something that I maybe haven't thought
of yet and that's the mark of life I
think like a great director is like it's
not all my vision it's this
collaboration so that's you know seeing
you work with the other actors was
really a treat for me to see to see you
give them space in like life to breathe
and play you blush and yet can you talk
a little bit about just like the tone in
the vibe of the movie because one thing
I thought made it super powerful is I
mean we all know where it goes in the
end but there's no there's almost like a
levity and a purity to it at the
beginning that really let me kind of
fall in the step with all the characters
and feel like I was part of their lives
so can you tell me a little bit about
handling on that that on sex I'm sure
you can't shoot in sequence which might
be yeah I think for me it's a the tone
is one of the most difficult things to
manage and wrap your hands around when
you're making a film it's like such a
vital part of directing and with this
one it has these three different stories
and they all have these different
flavors within each of those stories as
well so I'm like I don't know I feel
like like the way I like to eat is I'm
very I like a smoothie or like a salad
that you just like throw a bunch of
different stuff in there and you shake
it all around and then it's like oh and
it's you get these new things you know
it's like so you can't have something
that's it's a drama but you don't have
to be drab and joyless and like checking
your watch because like we're mopey but
it's like no you want to reflect life
you want to laugh and then all of a
sudden you turn the corner and
something devastating happens and then
cut to many other cares and you're
laughing like that that's that's how
life feels to me and I wanted the film
to kind of like flow like that in a way
success in that department it definitely
does was there any particular scene in
the film without spoiling anything that
you found yourself work shopping on set
more so than others there were
definitely some of the like outside of
like our actors lives experiences that
we really wanted to just make sure that
in the same sense of like keeping you
guys comfortable and and and having the
space to explore we wanted to just kind
of rehearse those parts out to get it
really really just ingrained in your
mind so that you could you could play
and find your own version of that on the
day specifics would kind of give away
some of the story stuff but yeah I mean
it but it's also fun to like play with
like what teenage love means to me you
know like what that was for me and how
to sort of like reflect those moments
and you guys it's such a great job of
you guys did such a great job of sort of
encapsulating that is really incredible
we talked about that in another
interview words that's the hardest thing
to play is that love impulse cuz you you
can't be self-conscious you know when
you have that feeling for somebody you
just go you know me you you you can't
help yourself you know you want them to
know and find that if they feel the same
way you do and the freedom that all
three of them exhibit that mean isn't
that the hardest thing to do as an
actress to be free you're so
self-conscious and you're wondering how
am i how am i coming across am i putting
across what what I think is right what
he thinks is right whatever am i serving
the material and and all of them were
did a wonderful job and understand that
the basis of acting is freedom is to be
free and for the camera well
congratulations on your award
congratulations on your movie thank you
again for came here another thank you to
the fine folks at the Kia Telluride
supper suite for having us here Collider
interviews we're having a wonderful time
in Park City like and share this one
before you go and we'll see you soon
with more of them